The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: OK, so
today I would like to cover--
to start, well, I will
do a lot of things today.
But to begin with, I would
like to solve two applications
of Fermat's principle.
And the simplest possible thing
that we try to do in optics,
and that is to focus.
So the one focus will
come up again and again.
It basically refers
to the idea--
hi, Colin.
It refers to the idea that we
have rays, a bundle of rays
that are propagating.
And focusing means that we try
to force these rays to meet
at one point.
So this, of course, is
very useful for imaging,
but even simpler, if
you want to collect
all of the light
energy, for example,
for a solar concentrator,
or a satellite dish,
or something like that.
Then basically, this
is what you try to do.
You try to get the rays that
are coming from the source,
and focus them into a point.
And this is valid, of
course, in the entire regime
of electromagnetic waves--
whether microwaves, or visible
light, or even higher--
provided that the element
that we use to focus the rays
is much bigger than
the wavelength.
And here, I'm leaving
it deliberately vague
how much bigger.
But think about it that is maybe
a few thousand of wavelengths,
or few hundred of wavelengths.
In the microwave case,
that's not exactly true.
The RF wavelength maybe
a couple of centimeters.
The typical satellite
dish is about the meter,
so we're talking about
50 to 100 wavelength.
But anyway, still the
approximations are valid.
So the simplest way to
do this kind of operation
to focus the light into a
point so it can be detected
is with a reflector, a mirror
whose surface is curved.
And you know from experience
if you look at the spoon
that, well, funny things happen
if you look at the spoon.
We will talk about that
perhaps a little bit later.
But you know that the
spoon forms images,
so this is basically a
simplification or idealization
of a spoon.
So let's say that we
have this surface.
And for now, even though the
label says parabolic reflector,
I will pretend that I don't
know the shape of the surface.
So s of x is an unknown
to be determined.
And the goal, of
course, is to have
rays that are coming as parallel
rays onto the parabol line,
onto this unknown shape.
And our goal is to
focus these rays
into a point on the
axis of the surface.
And what you see.
You see here that I put
the symbol of infinity.
I will mention that
also a little bit later.
If we have rays that are
parallel, you can think--
according to Euclidean geometry,
parallel rays never meet.
Or another way to say it is
that parallel rays, if they ever
meet, that would be at infinity,
at a very, very long distance
away.
So when the object
of the imaging system
is very far away, such
as the sun, or a star,
or a really remote source.
Then we can say that
the ray is coming
from that object
that are parallel,
or that are coming
from infinity.
So the objective here
is, again, to determine
the shape of the
surface, s of x, such
that the rays all
focus at a point, f.
So there's a number
of ways of doing it.
One is for example, I can apply
the law of reflection anywhere
in the surface.
I have the array appearing here.
I can compute the
normal to the ray--
I'm sorry, the
normal to the surface
at that point of
existence of the ray.
And I can apply the
law of reflection.
I can solve the
problem this way.
But that is actually a very
complicated way of solving it.
Much work.
So being, I guess, lazy.
The best way to
solve this problem
is to invoke the
Fermat's principle.
And Fermat's principle
says, again, to remind you,
says that rays that
depart from a common point
and arrive at another point.
They have to follow the
minimum optical path.
A corollary to
that is that if you
have two rays that
start at the same point
and meet again at
the same point,
then these rays must
follow the same path.
Because if one of those
rays follows a shorter path,
it means that the other ray
that followed the longer path
is violating Fermat's principle.
And that cannot happen.
So the way we're
thinking about this here
is to take, for
example, the center
ray that is going directly on
axis, that started at infinity.
We go to the reflector.
It will be reflected
exactly backwards,
and will go through
the focal point, f.
If we take another
ray that is away
from the central axis
of the unknown surface.
Then this ray also
started at infinity.
It gets reflected, and then,
again, meets at that point, f.
So therefore, the pattern
that these two rays followed
must be the same.
So how do we compute this path?
Well, if you look
at the central ray.
The central ray is
coming from infinity.
I will use the plane passing
through the focal point
as my reference.
And I will calculate
the path back and forth
from the focal point to
the reflector and back.
So I basically
calculate this path.
This path obviously
equals 2 times f.
By f, I denote the focal
distance of the reflector.
That is the distance at which
the rays come to a focus.
And the other path
I will compute
is I will ignore the path of the
ray up to the reference plane.
And then I will compute
this path over here.
So how do you compute this path?
Well, the shape of the
paraboloid is s of x.
So basically, s of x is the
elevation of the unknown shape
with respect to the
other reference plane
that passes through the
bottom of the unknown shape.
So therefore, this
distance here is f minus s,
because it equals the focal
distance minus the elevation
of the reflector.
And the other-- this
distance over here.
OK, so let me write it down.
So it is f minus s.
This is the first
segment of the ray part.
And the other is the hypotenuse
of this orthogonal triangle,
where one side of the
triangle equals x.
The other side of the
triangle equals f plus s.
And all I have to do is I have
to apply Pythagoras' theorem.
OK, so this is the path of
the ray that arrived away
from the optical axis.
And, of course, this
must equal the path
of the ray that is exactly on
the axis that equals to 2f.
So now, we can play with
his formula a little bit.
I skip the derivation
in the notes.
Actually, I didn't quite skip
the derivation of the notes.
So instead of deriving it
here, I will just animate it.
And if we do the
algebra here, we
can basically eliminate
one of the focal distances,
bring that to the other side.
And then do a little bit
more algebraic manipulation.
And after not too much work, we
have this expression over here
for the elevation of
the unknown shape.
And clearly, what you see
over that is a parabola.
Of course, it turned
out to be a parabola
because I did the calculation
in the cross section--
in one cross section
of the optical element.
In reality, all
of these elements
are rotationally symmetric
surfaces of revolution.
So the reason I
call it a paraboloid
and not a parabola is
because I take this shape,
and then I spin it
around the optical axis
in order to get
the familiar ball
shape of the paraboloid this.
But to do a little
less math here,
and to keep my life simple, I
will only do these calculations
in one plane.
So turns out to be
a simple parabola.
So then this is
your final answer.
This is the shape
of a reflector that
will take a set
of parallel rays,
and focus them into a
focal point in front
of the reflector.
So these are very nice.
And we actually got our
first imaging system.
We managed to compute
its focal length
as a function of the
shape of the element.
There's a few things that I
would like to remark here.
One is, for example, that
this works very nicely when
the rays are indeed incident
parallel to the normal
at the center of
the parabola here.
If you imagine that I take
this set of rays and I tilt it.
Then a little bit of thought
will convince yourself
that it doesn't work
so nicely anymore.
If you were to then
come in parallel rays,
then the rays will
kind of focus,
but they would fail to meet all
at once at the focal point, f.
So this is a perfect
focusing element
for on axis incident rays.
But it would be not
so perfect anymore
if the rays are
arriving off axis.
That's one observation
to keep in mind.
This will come up again later.
One thing I would like
to say is that this
is a very nice element, indeed.
But in some cases,
it is not practical
because as you can see,
the focus is actually
in front of the element.
So if you were to
detect the light,
you would have to put,
for example, a photo diode
or some transducer at
this location, which
means you are actually
blocking the path of the light.
AUDIENCE: I have
a quick question.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: I'm
sorry, I can not hear you.
AUDIENCE: I can understand
how the rays have
a minimal optical path.
But I don't understand
why they have
to have the same optical path.
For example, you let
it equal to 2f, which
was at the center distance.
So isn't it possible that the
minimum optical path does not
equal 2f?
Or why is that the case?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Take two rays.
In our case, one ray [INAUDIBLE]
from infinity, and they both
meet at F. So the rays can
take different optical paths.
One can go like this, the
other can go like this.
And doing our rays in general.
So imagine that this has path
l1, and this has path l2.
And imagine, for the
sake of argument,
that l1 is less than l2.
Fermat's principle says
that if the ray, number one,
goes through the first
point from the origin
to the destination.
It follows a certain path.
This path has to be minimal.
But now, look at ray number two.
This ray also goes from the same
origin to the same destination,
but follows a
longer optical path.
Therefore, the second ray has
to violate Fermat's principle.
So this is what we call
mathematics abduction to--
what do you call it?
To absurdum.
That's right,
abduction to absurdum.
In other words, by
assuming that the rays have
unequal optical
paths, we arrived
at a conclusion that is
inconsistent with Fermat's
principle.
So therefore, this
has to be discarded.
The only possibility
is that l1 equals l2.
So because the two rays
start at the same origin
and arrive at the
same destination,
they must have the
same optical path.
Did that make sense?
AUDIENCE: For example, in
the homework problem, where
you have the swimmer and the
lifeguard, well, I guess--
I'll think about
it a little more.
Yeah, makes sense.
Thanks.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: OK.
So for the cases where the
paraboloid is not convenient.
Actually, I should
say for the cases
where the reflector
is not convenient,
because of the problem
of blocking the ray
path at the focal point.
It is perhaps more
convenient to attempt
to use a refractive optical
element that is a dielectric.
And try to focus the rays using
now, again, a curved surface.
But in this case, it is a curved
surface refractive index n.
And for simplicity,
I will assume
that the rays are, again,
are coming from free space,
from vacuum, or from air.
So the index of
refraction is actually
one on the left
hand side over here.
On the right hand side, it is n.
So in this case, again,
I have the same problem.
I have an unknown shape, s
of x, that I should follow,
that I must somehow
shape my refractor.
And one could assume
that this is anything.
It could be, again, a parabola.
It could be a circle,
I mean, a sphere.
It could be a number
of different things.
The question, what is it really.
So the question is actually
the same as the question
that I asked before.
And to answer it, we will
actually follow once again
the same argument.
We will use Fermat to argue
that since the two rays started
at the same point, infinity.
And they meet at the same
point, F, at the same target,
F. They must follow
the same optical path.
So in this case, I will apply
Fermat with the reference plane
that is tangential at the
apex of the known refractive--
I'm sorry, of the
unknown refractor shape.
And I will compute the
path of the own axis
ray, which is very easy.
So this path, you have to
be a little bit careful now
when we define the optical path.
If you remember, the
optical path in general.
Optical path length
equals the integral
along the ray trajectory of the
index of refraction times dl.
So what this means
now in our case
is that the optical path
length for this segment
of the rays between the
apex and the focal point
equals f, the distance, times
the index of refraction,
in order to convert it
to proper optical path.
OK, so that's easy.
Now, we have to
compute the other one.
So here's, again, I will
exaggerate it a little bit.
Here is, again, my
unknown shape, s of x.
And here is the ray that is
arriving at some distance, x,
from the apex.
And this ray, according
to my postulate here,
will meet the axis
at distance small f.
To reach the point, uppercase
f, that is the focal point.
So again, I have to do a
little bit of geometry here.
This distance is s of x.
Because this distance, again, is
the elevation of the refractor
shape relative to my
reference plane over here.
So this equals s plus this
distance, which again, is
the hypotenuse of a triangle.
But I have to be, again,
a little bit careful
because this segment
over here now,
again, is inside the refractor.
So before I do
anything else, again, I
have to multiply by the
index of refraction.
So it has to be n, the
index of refraction,
times the hypotenuse
length, which
equals the square
root of the two sides,
of the two sides squared.
What am I doing?
I'm sorry.
x squared plus f
minus s squared.
That's the correct expression.
OK, and [INAUDIBLE] in
fact I could see it,
because my computer
has a preview.
So I can see the
equation, but I'm
trying not to see it when
I'm deriving things here.
OK, so that is the
equation, then.
So again, according
to the argument.
Actually, let me repeat it
once again, because this
is a-- it's a very basic point.
We have two rays here.
One is going on axis.
There is no refraction here,
because it is incident exactly
normally on the surface.
And then it propagates
at distance, f.
So the optical path length
of this ray equals n times f.
Then I have another ray that
propagated a little bit further
in there because it arrives
at the elevated portion
of the refractor.
And then it bends in some
way that we don't know yet.
But what we do know
is that we want,
we demand, we
require, so to speak,
this ray to go through
the same point, F.
So the fact that the ray goes
through the same point, F.
It means that it must follow the
same path as the one axis ray.
If this ray, for example,
had followed a shorter path.
Then there's no reason for
this ray to go this way.
It should have gone
this way as well,
because if it
hadn't, it would be
violating Fermat's principle.
That is the argument.
So therefore, there
are two paths.
This path, and this path.
They must be exactly equal.
So this is what this
equation says over that.
OK, this equation now.
Does anybody know what
this equation represents?
If you have looked at
the notes ahead of time,
you know the answer.
If you ever looked at
the notes, this equation
doesn't mean much.
However, it can be manipulated.
And I did not do all the
algebra in the notes.
I skipped a few steps.
So the first thing you
do is you basically try
to get rid of the square root.
So you bring this
s on that side.
You take squares of both sides.
You do a little bit of algebra.
You bring it to this form.
Then this-- it still
doesn't look very nice.
So what you do is you try
to write it to complete
the sum of squares here.
So that's a little bit messy.
I will let you do it by
yourselves, if you're
interested and curious.
If you get stuck, and you
don't know how to do it,
I will post the complete
derivation on the website.
But anyway, after a
little bit more algebra,
you get a result
that looks like this.
It looks like a square
of the surface shape, s,
minus the displacement,
times another square
of the coordinate x
equals a constant.
And this type of
equation in general,
an equation of the form
s square over constant,
plus x square over constant
equals another constant, which
might as well be one.
This equation
represents an ellipse.
It is still not quite like this.
It is of the form s minus some
constant square over constant
plus x square over
constant equals 1.
That is still in ellipse, but
a displaced ellipse, right?
What this really means
is that the ellipse
is centered at this location.
OK, this comes from
the displacement term
in the square.
And the eccentricity of
the ellipse-- that is,
the size of the minor axis
relative to the major axis--
is given by the inverse of
this quantity over here.
So it is n minus
1 over n plus 1f.
What is interesting to note
is that the focal point
is to the right hand side of
the center of the ellipse.
And in fact, this happens to be
the focal point of the ellipse.
If you look at the
definition of an ellipse
in the form of pure
geometry, ellipses
are characterized
by two focal points.
And it turns out in this
case, the focus of the rays
is one of the focal
points of the ellipse.
And that, of course,
is symmetrically
located on the other side.
OK, so this is a bit of
a mathematical trickery.
But what I want to
emphasize, which is actually
kind of important to know,
is that the focal point
is actually past the
center of the ellipse.
That's about it, really.
The result of this is sort
of an ideal elliptical shape.
That's something
worth remembering.
That if you have a ideal
set of parallel rays coming
in-- or as we will call
it a little bit later,
a plane wave--
and we wish to focus it at
the final distance inside
of the electric material.
The best possible
shape to achieve
that is an elliptical shape.
Now, again, there's caveats.
For example, if I tilt
this incoming ray,
then the focus will not
be perfect out here.
So this is the same situation
as in the parabol line.
It only works so
nice and so perfectly
if the incidence
is exactly normal.
Out of curiosity,
can anybody imagine--
so if you compare this
with a paraboloid,
one obvious advantage
is, of course,
that I'm not blocking
the light path anymore.
What is a possible disadvantage
of this kind of approach?
There are several, actually.
Tell me at least one.
Yeah.
Push the button.
AUDIENCE: The detector
is inside the vector.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: That's
one obvious disadvantage.
If I wanted to
really use this, I
would have to put
the detector here.
And, of course, it doesn't
have to be a full ellipse.
I can always clip the
ellipse over here.
The rays have no way of knowing
that this happened to them,
so I can always stick
the detector over here.
So maybe I can
overcome that problem.
But it is a problem, yeah.
What is the second problem
that kind of is sticking out?
AUDIENCE: In the
case of if you're
trying to build a
telescope, or something
where you have to worry
about the structure
of your optical setup.
You could think that maybe
a solid element would
be much more bulky
or hard to abrogate
than a reflecting
element, like paraboloid?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's correct.
If you tried to
make a big element,
a big lens, a big
focusing concentrator,
like a solid concentrate,
or a satellite dish.
That's a very inconvenient
shape to have.
It is heavy--
absolutely, I agree.
Tell me a third disadvantage.
The paraboloid can go
on a very long distance.
This one is a finite shape
because it's an ellipse.
As it curves at some point, it
will reach a derivative equal
to zero.
It will stop there.
So basically, this element
captures only a finite set
of rays up to the minor
axis of the ellipse.
It is missing the rest.
Tell me a fourth and final
disadvantage of this setup
that at least I could think of.
I'll give you a hint.
Last time, Piper did a very
nice demonstration with a prism.
Do you remember something
that his demonstration--
something about this
demonstration [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: There can be
total internal reflection.
Like on this
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
[INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Is there
a possibility for PIR here?
AUDIENCE: The
index of refraction
isn't necessarily the
same for all wavelengths?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: So
first of all, let's answer
the previous question.
Here, you're right to think
about the possibility of PIR.
But if you look at it in
a little bit more detail,
you will see that PIR is
not a problem in this case.
At least for the rays
going up to here,
there's no problem of PIR.
Because the rays
come from a low index
medium to a high index medium.
And therefore, they will always
refract inside the [INAUDIBLE]..
What is interesting to
happen to the ray that
is incident exactly tangential
to the ellipse over here.
It will still be refracted,
if you think about it.
It's Snell's law.
And it will give you sort
of the maximum acceptance
cone of the interface that
we discussed last week,
I mean, on Monday in
relation to Snell's law.
So then out of the two demos
that Piper did last week,
the PIR is not the problem.
It is the other one, as
you correctly pointed out.
So you want to repeat?
Who has spoken before?
Someone mentioned the
index of refraction.
AUDIENCE: The
index of refraction
isn't the same for
all wavelengths.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's right.
So since the index
of refraction is not
the same for all
wavelengths, what this means
is that the focal distance
now becomes a function
of the index of refraction.
And I may tune it.
Basically, what I do is
I manufacture this shape.
So I can manufacture
it for a certain index
for a standard wavelength.
If the index changes,
this relation
will not be satisfied
anymore, and therefore
the refractive element
will become imperfect.
How do we call this phenomenon
of dependence of index
of refraction on wavelength?
Dispersion.
And in the context that
we're discussing here.
OK, it is dispersion.
In the context of
focusing, when we
get imperfect focusing
because of dispersion,
It has also another
special name.
It is called
chromatic aberration.
The term aberration we'll
see again in the next hour.
It generally refers to
failures of optical systems
to focus light as
they're supposed to.
So this is the first such
failure that we encounter.
The term chromatic, I have
an advantage over you.
I'm Greek.
And this turns out
to be a Greek word.
Chroma in Greek means color.
And this is the Greek spelling.
If you want to spell it out in
Latin so you can pronounce it,
it is chroma.
And that's where the word
chromatic is derived from.
It literally means
separation due to color.
Any questions on
any of this so far?
I'm sorry, there's a question.
AUDIENCE: If someone thought
of a lenslike element
in which the
focusing takes place
on the other side
of the element.
Will it have a
[INAUDIBLE] power surface?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's coming up, actually,
in a few slides.
So yeah, I mean, the answer
to your question is generally,
if you want to focus
a point from the left
to a point on the right, at
the opposite side of element.
You need two hyperbolic surface.
I'll cover that in a second.
Of course, hyperbolas are
difficult to manufacture.
People typically make
spherical surfaces.
You can also have a sphere,
nowadays, by injection molding.
I will go into that also later.
But even that is only
perfect for on axis points.
If you move points off
axis, then it fails again.
So it becomes the whole
problem of optical design.
OK, so I will switch now
to today's, actually,
set of lectures.
And you realized that
we were kind of behind
by almost one lecture.
I think we're beginning
to catch up now.
But what I would like to do
today for the rest of the two
hours that you have is
to go relatively slowly
over a number of
different topics, which
are also related to focusing.
But as we go along,
we will generalize
focusing to more and more
complicated situations.
So I wanted to solve
two cases of-- actually,
one case of focusing using two
different types of elements,
a reflector and a refractor.
In order to make this stuff
a little bit more specific,
let me remind you
of some definitions
that we discussed a little
bit at the first lecture.
But I would like to remind you
again with a bit more detail.
So what is the concept
of a spherical wave.
So spherical wave
is what you get
if you have light or
originating at the point source.
It is also referred
to as a point object.
So what happens then
is you get the fan
of rays that is divergent.
And if you plug the normals
to these rays, these normals,
they look like spheres.
So, of course, the wavefronts
expand as the spherical wave
propagates.
And because these wavefronts
are spherical surfaces,
that's why we call
it a spherical wave.
Again, very important to
remember by definition.
The wavefront is
normal to the rays.
So what I have done here in
principle is I took each ray.
I computed the
normal to the ray.
I connected all the normals,
and I get this sphere over here.
I don't know if I did it very
well in my graphic over here,
but that's what this
is supposed to denote.
OK, you can flip this
situation and create
a convergent spherical
wave, where basically, you
have rays that are
propagating towards the point.
If that is the case, it is
not a point source anymore.
You call it a point image.
In most optical systems-- at
least in optical systems that
we will consider here--
this is really the goal
of an optical system.
You try to take
rays of light that
are given to you by some
source that you do not control,
such as an object, or a
star far out of reach.
And what you try to do is you
try to arrange your optics,
select your lenses,
space them appropriately,
and so on and so forth.
So that you can converge
these incoming rays
into point images.
So if you wish this is our
given, or our customer.
And then this is what
the customer wants.
The customer wants
to form point images.
So a good deal of working
the field of optics
has to do with this
problem, how you can image--
however you can
create point images.
I'll take this out,
because it does not
relate to this discussion.
OK.
So again, the
wavefronts are spherical
here with a common center
at the point image.
But in this case, of
course, the wavefronts
are contracting as you go
towards the point image,
because the rays are converging.
And, of course, [AUDIO OUT]
wavefronts ideally collapse
into a point.
This doesn't sound
very physical.
And a little bit later, when we
do the theory of diffraction.
We will see in a bit more detail
what happens at that point.
It is not really that the
wavefront ideally collapses.
Something else happens
that we will see.
Within the geometrical
optics approximation,
let's accept it for now
that this is the case.
That indeed, the rays can
converge to a single point,
and then the wavefront
over there collapses.
OK, this is true for pretty
much every case of imaging.
However, in a number
of situations,
it is very convenient
to take one extreme case
where the point source, or the
point object is very far away.
I mentioned that already
about half an hour ago.
And I called it the
point source of infinity,
or a point object of infinity.
A very good approximation
for that is a star.
If we look at stars in the night
sky, they look like points.
Of course, a star is humongous.
It is probably thousands of
times bigger than the earth.
But because it is at a distance
of thousands or millions
of light years away,
it appears to us
to be like a point,
a point source.
So again, there's another
important point to emphasize.
When we talk about the
point object at infinity,
we don't necessarily imply
that it is mathematically
a point, that is, it
has zero dimension.
What we really mean
is it is so far
away that the angle that
I subtend towards that
far away point is minimal.
If that is true, if
that assumption is true,
then I can call it a point.
I mean, I can call it a
point source at infinity.
And what happens if you
really went near that point
far at infinity, you would
still see divergent rays.
But because these rays propagate
at a very long distance,
you only get to see the
set of rays near the axis
that departed from that point.
And because you're
[INAUDIBLE],, these rays
are really tightly collapsed
near the central ray over here.
They all look parallel.
So a set of rays that I
propagate and they're parallel.
Like so on here, we
call it a plane wave.
If you go back to your notes
from the first lecture,
we called it the plane wave,
or the planar wavefront.
But we can also call it--
parallel [INAUDIBLE]
rays, we can also
call it an object at infinity.
Of course, because
the rays are parallel.
If I draw the normals to
them, they will form planes.
They form ideal planar surfaces.
And that's why this
is called the planar
wavefront, or a plane wave.
For our purposes, the
two terms are identical.
And, of course, this
goes the other way too.
If I had a planar wave
also propagating like this.
I can also claim that I create
a point image at infinity.
Because if I take
parallel lines and I
propagate them for an
infinitely long distance.
OK, what I'm about to say is
not mathematically correct,
but in optics, we
say it all the time.
It is that these parallel
rays will meet at infinity.
Of course, parallel
rays never meet.
But you can simply to
justify it in your mind,
flip to this picture,
and take these rays,
propagate them backwards.
At a very, very
far away distance,
you cannot tell the difference,
whether they started
as parallel rays, or they
started as a tightly convergent
small ray bundle.
OK, so this [AUDIO OUT]
because very often,
it simplifies
calculations and gives
certain kinds of intuition.
And again, we define it in
the geometric optic sense.
When we do diffraction
about a month from now,
we will define it more
rigorously in a way
that is probably much more
convincing than I do now.
The reason I'm apologizing
for this definition
is that there's no such thing
as mathematical infinity
in real life.
Even a star, it is a
very long distance away,
but it is not an
infinite distance away.
So what do I mean by infinity?
For example, [INAUDIBLE],, who is
sitting here on the front row.
Is he at infinity with
respect to me, or no?
Well, what about you guys who
are sitting in the cam bridge?
Well, OK, the surface
of the earth is curved,
so that creates an
obvious problem.
But suppose I could
draw a straight line
through the center of the
earth from Singapore to Boston.
Would you guys be at
infinity with respect to me?
OK, it actually depends on
a lot of different things.
It depends on the relative
sizes that I have and you have.
It depends on the wavelength
that the light is propagating.
And actually, that's
about it, according
to diffraction theory.
So we will see a rigorous
definition of what is infinity
when we do diffraction.
For now, let's take
it on faith that if I
have a set of rays that
appear [AUDIO OUT],,
we'll call it image of infinity.
So sometimes, we use
the term collimated.
That's a better marker.
Collimated rays.
So collimated is from
the word colinear, right?
Creating parallel to each other.
OK.
So I included this slide,
but as a reminder, and that
as a reference,
because for the next--
I don't know, for the next
semester really, from now on,
we'll be using
these terms a lot.
Spherical waves, plane
waves, spherical wavefronts,
and so on and so forth.
The concept of
infinity applies to
both convergent and divergent
spherical waves at infinity.
All right.
So the two examples that
we saw at the beginning.
These are basically examples
of imaging sources at infinity.
Because we had
plane waves coming
into the paraboloidal
reflector and ellipsoidal
refractor respectively.
And then these two
elements managed
to convert these plane
waves, these parallel
ray bundles into perfect
converging spherical waves.
Therefore, they created
perfect point images
at the corresponding
focal points.
And then wavefronts,
I also put down
the two equations, the
equations of the two elements.
Now, let's flip the coin
a little bit, and ask
how can I create a
point image at infinity?
Now, I start with a point
source that is within my range.
Here is my point source.
And I'm trying to
create an image
of that source of infinity.
Well, another way to say it
is that what I'm trying to do
is I'm trying to
collimate the light.
So in the case of
the paraboloid,
it's actually very simple.
All I have to do is reverse
the paths of the rays.
This may also sound arbitrary,
but in electromagnetics,
there's a very basic principle
that says that you can do that.
I will not go into
that in detail,
but I can assure you that from
the rigorous electromagnetic
point of view, this
is permissible.
You can reverse the ray
paths, and you still
get the value of the
electromagnetic field.
Therefore, a paraboloidal
reflector works both ways.
You can use it
either as a receiver,
so you can focus a
source at infinity,
and you can detect it here.
Or it's a transmitter.
You can have a point source
at this finite distance,
and you can broadcast a number
of cars, but you can beam it.
That's the word.
You can beam it
to a very narrow--
to a target that is at a
very long distance away.
In the case of a refractor,
the answer is not as simple.
Because in the process of
reversing the situation,
now, the source is in air.
And the collimated light is in
glass, is in the dielectric.
So therefore, the ellipse
doesn't necessarily
provide the same answer anymore.
So basically, you have to
solve the problem again.
And indeed, we find
that the ellipse is not
the answer in this case.
The answer is a hyperbola.
A hyperboloidal surface.
Given by this
equation over here.
If you compare it with
the case of the ellipse,
the difference is a minus sign.
So again, I will not
do this derivation.
I will let you do
it by yourselves
if you have the inclination.
Or if we have time at the
end today, we might do it.
It's a very similar derivation.
We apply Fermat's principle.
We basically demand
that the path
from here to some reference
point equals the path from here
to the same reference
plane off axis.
When you apply
this principle, you
end up with this equation after
some algebraic manipulation.
So the word confusion.
I actually put
together a table that
contains all the
possible cases of first
of all, reflective versus
refractive focusing elements.
And point sources, or
point images at infinity.
And there's actually
six possible cases.
For the kinds of a reflector,
we saw that it doesn't really
make a difference.
In both cases, a
paraboloid is the answer.
Because I computed
already the focusing
of an object at
infinity, which is
focused at the focal
point of the paraboloid.
And if I reverse the
rays, the same paraboloid
will take a point source at
F, and image that point source
at infinity.
So that is very simple.
In the case of a dielectric,
I can do two things.
First of all, I start
with the ellipsoid.
When we derive the
case of the ellipsoid,
focusing a plane wave
coming from infinity.
And we saw that it focuses at
the focal point of the ellipse,
inside the ellipse.
If I reverse the
array paths, then I
have this situation where
the light originates
at the center of the ellipse.
And then it gets
collimated as it comes out.
Now, the reason the
ellipse is still the answer
here is because the light
starts at the dielectric.
So really, now, I'm correct.
I can still revise
the optical path,
and I get the correct answer.
So this has led to cases
of objects at infinity,
and image at infinity.
But have to be careful
that the object is in air.
In this case, the object
of infinity is in air.
The focus is inside
the dielectric.
In this case, the
source of the object
is inside the dielectric,
and the image at infinity
is in air.
The other case is
the one that I just
mentioned, and did
not derive, but I
let you derive by yourselves.
And that is the case
of a source that
is now at a finite distance.
And I wish the image to be at
infinity inside the dielectric.
So this case, this is
hyperboloidal surface.
And, of course, you
might ask, well,
what the heck does
it really mean?
Can I really make an
infinitely large refractor?
Well, that says you don't
have to, because if any
of the refractor is cut here.
Since the rays are
coming out normal,
they do not refract at
all at this interface.
So really, you can
chop the hyperbola,
and then you can still have your
point, your image at infinity.
So that's fine.
And, of course, you can also
reverse the ray paths here.
And you can create
the opposite situation
where whenever you have
an object at infinity,
but inside the dielectric.
And you have a point image
at a finite distance in air.
And that could also
be hyperbolic, right?
Because this, I derive simply
by flipping the ray paths
from one case to the next.
OK, any questions about this?
AUDIENCE: I've got a question.
If your point sources
within a green lens,
what is the corresponding
index of refraction function?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Within a green lens?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: I
will cover green lenses
in about two weeks.
We will do Hamiltonian
optics, so yeah.
AUDIENCE: I also
have a question.
So if you said with the
hyperboloidal refractor,
if you cut off the
back end, the rays
will continue to
come out parallel.
Does that work in the
opposite direction?
Like if you have a lens that's
flat on one end and a hyperbola
on the other, can you
focus it to a random point?
Or not random.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yes.
This case, for example,
that would work.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I can't see.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: If you
have rays coming in, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
right, yeah.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Of course, the problem
if you do it this way is
that you have to cut off
the hyperbol at some point.
So you cannot extend your
incoming bundle infinitely.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Of course, these
are all very highly idealized
situations, I should emphasize.
Any other questions?
OK, so now that you
have seen these,
I would like to say a few
things about wavefronts,
and what happens
to the wavefronts
as they go through of these--
AUDIENCE: George, I think
that's another question.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Oh yeah, I'm sorry.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So would the
ellipsoidal reflector
also be more subject to
spherical aberrations
since the focal point is
actually within the optic
instead of in front of it?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Say that again?
If it is in front?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
it's comparing the--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
OK, I have not yet
defined what is
spherical aberration.
Assuming that we know what
spherical aberration is.
All of these are free
of spherical aberration.
By construction, they
focus light perfectly.
However, a spherical aberration
will come in, for example,
if you--
let's take this case.
Yeah, if you move
the source off axis,
then the plane wave of
coming out will be aberrated.
The same here.
If you tilt this plane wave.
Again, the point image
will be aberrated.
Actually, it would be
aberrated in more than one way.
It will contain comma
as well as spherical
So these are free of
aberrations to the degree
that they are also
operated as design.
But we'll say a little
bit about aberrations
in the coming slides.
So maybe you can postpone that.
Any other questions?
So speaking of aberrations,
here they come.
First of all, let me say a few
things about the wavefronts.
So by definition, I will
just look at this case,
and then you can
construct similar diagrams
for all the six cases that
were in the previous slide.
I didn't want to do that.
It actually takes a very
long time to do such a slide,
so I didn't want
to do all of them.
But this is pretty
representative.
So it conveys the idea, I think.
So by definition, we have
a plane wave coming in.
So you have plane wavefronts
arriving at the interface.
And also by definition,
because by construction
we required all the rays,
all the refractive rays.
They are required to meet at
the focal point over here.
It means that what
we have inside
the refractor is
converging spherical waves.
And therefore, if you look at
the wavefronts collapsing in
towards the focal point,
they are perfect spheres.
This is all equal section,
so these are perfect spheres
collapsing towards
uppercase F. It's
kind of interesting to
think what happens here
at the interface.
So [INAUDIBLE] the interface,
you have two things happening.
You have the ray arriving at
the left, then sort of being
refracted into the sphere.
But the wavelength
has to remain--
well, it has to
remain continuous.
So basically, what
happens is the wavefronts,
they curve in a continuous
fashion, as shown here.
You can think of it basically
as the wave approaches
from the left toward
the refractor,
as it starts entering
the refractor, of course,
it enters first at the apex.
And then the wavefront
starts bulging.
It sort of creates this bulge.
And then as it goes
more and more in,
the bulge progresses to create a
segment of a spherical surface.
Now, you can justify that with
a number of different ways.
One is, of course, Fermat's
principle that we just applied.
The other is if you
think that light actually
propagates slower in this medium
than it propagates in air,
then you can see why the
wavefront starts bulging here.
Because as soon as the light
enters the medium, it gets
slowed down.
So now that portion
of the wavefront
that is still outside
in air is actually
faster than the
portion that is here.
Even if you compare,
let's take this case.
If you compare the portion
of the wavefront that is here
at the apex to the
portion that is here,
to the portion that is here.
You can see that this one
has traveled the longer
distance in the medium.
So that's why it
is further behind.
This one has traveled
slightly less,
so therefore, it is a
little bit further ahead.
And this one is still in air,
so it is even more ahead.
So this is another
way to explain
why the wavefronts
are bulging, and they
become spherical as the
wave enters the medium.
Now, of course, they
become exactly spherical.
It's very special to
shape that we chose.
Because we demanded
Fermat to hold,
the wavefronts that
result from refraction
of this elliptical interface.
They actually become spherical.
But you can easily
convince yourself
that if I chose a
different surface.
Say, if I chose a
sphere or a hyperbola
in this case, or some crazy
polynomial, quartic, sixth
order, I don't know,
some generalized surface.
Then the wavefronts
that we get here.
They might still bulge, because
the light would enter a slower
middle, but they
wouldn't be spherical.
Now, the fact that
the wavefronts
would not be spherical.
What it really implies is
that the focus is not perfect
anymore.
If these surfaces
of the wavefronts,
they deviate from spheres.
Then the rays would not
really all be at [? F, ?]
but they would cross
at various places.
And that is what you
call an aberrated image,
or an aberrated wavefront.
So the two are related, because
if, for example, the wavefront
deviates from a sphere, then you
call it an aberrated wavefront.
If the image deviates from
the ideal point image, where
all the rays meet to
a sort of blurry image
where the rays fail to meet,
then that's an aberrated image.
So I will show some
examples of that
later on, today, and also
later during the class.
So there's a special
case when the--
well, let me save that
special case for later.
I will talk about
this in a little bit.
What I would like to say next
is why is it so significant to--
why do we try so hard to
create these point images?
We're surrounded by
objects that are--
actually, most of the
objects that we see around us
are reflective.
They are opaque.
So light that is entered
in from a light source,
for example, a light
bulb, or the sunlight when
we're outdoors.
What happens to the light
as it hits the objects that
are surrounding us.
It scatters.
So scattering really
means that the light
that is arriving from a source.
Each point in the object, it
creates a highly divergent
spherical wave.
So basically, each
point in the object
becomes a secondary
point source.
This is part of a big--
of another principle
in light propagation
called the Huygen's principle.
But we're not quite ready
to see that principle yet.
It needs a little bit
more careful definition.
So for now, one way to
justify in your mind
why this might happen is that
the objects surrounding us.
They are composed of atoms.
And each atom, when it
gets hit by the light beam.
It will be set in motion.
And you can imagine
the situation
where the motion of the atom
will irradiate a new light
beam.
So these light beams
that are coming out
of there of the atoms composing
the surfaces surrounding us.
This is what we perceive as--
I should say, what we
receive as scattered light.
And it sounds a little
bit like hocus pocus,
but it's actually not
very far from reality.
You can justify
the argument I just
made with some very
basic principles.
So it is more or less correct.
The bottom line is
that the illumination
becomes these divergent
spherical wavefronts.
Now, if you are sitting
here, and you're
observing all the rays
coming from the object.
You can imagine
that it's a mess.
For example, here, you have
rays coming from this point,
and from this point,
from everywhere, everywhere
inside the object.
You have rays arriving here.
So it is very difficult to
understand what's going on.
All of these rays, they create
kind of a very blurred image,
very similar to what happens to
those of us who have glasses.
When we take off our glasses,
everything appears blurry.
Well, it is not as bad as it
would have been in this case.
But the reason things are blurry
in our eyes is because when we
take our glasses off, we
cannot form that effect--
well, it's never
perfect, but we can not
form good enough quality
images in our eye.
So what we need in order to
design these kind of situations
is an optical
system, or a sequence
of optical elements
that will pick up
these divergent
spherical wavefronts,
and will convert
them into converging
spherical wavefronts.
And if we can somehow
create an optical system
that will take each and every
one of these wavefronts.
Now, we're talking, of course,
about an infinitely large
number of point scatterers
that are generated here.
But if you can somehow take
each and every one of them,
and I can convert it into a
converging spherical wave, then
when I put all these converging
spherical waves together,
I will actually
get an image, which
will be as close to
perfect as I could possibly
want within the limits
of approximation
of geometrical optics.
Another way to express
it, which is really
like a fancy mathematical term,
but it is quite appropriate
here is the imaging
system creates a map.
Creates a map from point
sources in the object space
to point images in
the image space.
And this map is, of
course, very desirable.
Because if it fails, if I tried
to detect the image over here
that is before the rays
have come to focus.
Then the map
becomes ill-defined,
because each point over
here is receiving arrays
from multiple points
in the object.
This is exactly
the same situation
I was referring to before,
when we take off our glasses.
Those of us unfortunate
enough to require glasses.
For the rest of you who do not
need glasses in everyday life,
you can, of course,
create that same situation
by putting on a pair of
glasses that you can borrow
from one of your colleagues.
So in both cases,
you can add what
we call the focus,
which basically
means that the image is not just
imperfect, but it is blurry.
It is very far from perfect.
However, from what you
must have gathered already
from the previous discussion,
this is a very difficult task.
In fact, it is an
impossible task.
Because you saw that even
in the case of a simple,
ellipsoidal, or hyperboloidal
focusing element.
You could see that the one to
one mapping works only on axis.
If you tried to focus
simultaneously points off axis,
well, then, of course,
it stops to work.
It is very easy to convince
yourself in geometrical terms.
Even then, there is
some special cases
where you can have an entire
surface that is in focus.
But we will talk
about this later.
So this is actually--
you could think of it as
a very unfortunate event.
I think it as a fortunate
event, because it
keeps people like me,
and Professor Sheppard,
and a lot of colleagues,
it keeps us employed.
Because this is the
whole reason people
need optical systems is
they need people like us.
So it is a very fortunate fact.
But what I'm trying to say here
is that this job of perfect
imaging cannot be done exactly.
So therefore, the
science, or if you wish,
the engineering of
designing optical systems
is to arrive at the best
compromise within the cost,
constraints, the elements
that you have available,
the physics, of course, this
is definitely inviolable.
You can violate a budget, right?
You can run a
budget into the red,
as Wall Street banks discovered
in the last six months.
But you can certainly
not violate physics.
Even bankers cannot
violate physics.
So within all these constraints
imposed by physics, economics,
and so on so forth, how can
you make an imaging system that
does the best job possible?
OK, so let's go back
to this question
of how can we create good
enough quality images so that we
can design imaging systems?
So let's look at a slightly
different case, now.
So far, we saw pairs of
images and sources, where
one of the tools at infinity.
So objects at infinity,
finite images.
I mean, finite distant sources
and images at infinity.
We start to deal with this
case, where we have a point
object and a point image.
So both are now at
finite distances.
Based on what we saw so far,
and assuming that you're not
looking at your notes.
The answer is already
in your notes,
if you reach that
page in the notes.
But if you haven't seen that,
then your time to guess.
What would be the ideal
imager for this case that
would take a point object
and focus it perfectly
into a point image on axis?
Did we not answer
already based on--
AUDIENCE: The concatenation
of two hyperbolic reflectors.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's right.
So that is not necessarily
one way of doing it,
but it's certainly
one way of doing it
based on what we learn.
If I put two refractive
surfaces like this,
I can arrange the first
one to be a hyperbola.
What it will do is
it will collimate.
Yeah, it will collimate the
incident divergent wavefront.
And then if I can arrange
for the second one
to be also hyperbola,
then that will focus.
The plane wave that
was propagated here,
it will focus into a
perfect point image.
So this is now, again,
a perfect imager.
But now, it works
for finite distances.
One focal distance in
front of the hyperbola
to one focal distance
after the hyperbola.
And, well, just for
references, these
are the two questions
of the hyperbola.
I was a little bit
careful here to define
the axis, and the
displacement, and so on,
so that the question works.
I don't want to belabor that.
I let you go back and convince
yourself that it is correct,
or convince yourself that is
not correct, in which case,
please let me know so
that I can correct it.
But I think I got it right.
Anyway, so these are the two
equations of the hyperboloids.
And this is what in
optics is very often
referred to as an asphere.
Now, this can be
slightly confusing.
So I'm going to say
it a few times here,
and then I'm going to ask
you to go back home, read it
a few times, then print it out.
Post it in front of
your bathroom mirror
on top of your bed
and so on, whatever.
So you can see it a few
times, and memorize it.
OK, so this type of
element whose surface
is optimized to give a
desired focus and behavior
is called in asphere.
Again, I have a
benefit being Greek.
This A in front of the
sphere means not a sphere.
Give an example
from everyday life.
I can only think
technical terms,
and isotropic, aplanatic.
Give me an example of
from everyday life.
AUDIENCE: Atypical?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Atypical, there you are, yeah.
Thank you.
OK, so it is atypical
as in asphere.
So another term that
is very commonly used
is in aspheric lens.
Again, I want to emphasize
that this kind of a sphere.
It works perfectly on axis.
But as you can
imagine, if you were
to move this point object
off axis, it would go off.
It could create an image, but
it would be highly aberrated.
It would be subject to, well,
definitely spherical and comma
possibly.
It's a complicated story.
You can imagine that this
doesn't happen at the way.
There's probably a range over
here for point sources at that
near enough the axis that this
refractor would work actually
quite well.
So the question is can
I make such an element?
To answer this question,
I should tell you
a little bit about how optical
elements are usually made.
So what people at
least used to do
in the old days of
expensive optical elements,
is they would take
a piece of glass.
They would mount it
on a rotary stage.
Then they would bring a
diamond tip near the glass.
And they would start
rotating the glass.
And they would rotate basically
not at all at the center,
and they would let the
diamond touch the glass longer
and longer as they went away
from the tip of the glass.
The result of that
is, of course,
that you create a
spherical surface
if you move the diamond
at a fixed velocity.
So a fixed velocity
was very easy.
Because all you
needed is a model that
moves a diamond tip linearly.
That's pretty easy to do.
To make a hyperbola, you have
to plant the path of the diamond
tip in a way that results in
this nonuniform curvature.
So this used to be thought
as a very difficult task.
Come on in.
Someone's outside.
Don't be shy.
She changed her mind.
But in the last 20
years or so, the field
of mechatronics that many of
you are familiar with then
had advanced a lot.
So people who are able to
design diamond tools that
could very carefully plan
the path of the diamond tip,
and actually create aspheric
elements, such as this one.
But it still remains
very expensive.
So it could be an order of
magnitude difference in price.
If you need to compare
a spherical element,
compare it to an asphere.
Another
Major invention that helped this
business is injection molding.
Instead of actually
making the optical element
itself, what people
do nowadays is
they can make a very
expensive negative.
And then they inject
plastic into the negative.
They solidify the plastic,
and then they take it out.
And they can get any
arbitrary surface they want.
That's an OK way to make
a spheric optical element.
Nevertheless, spherical
elements remain very popular.
And there's a number of reasons
for these, [INAUDIBLE] spheres.
They can work very
well on axis, but they
can have other problems
that are perhaps
much more severe when they
go off axis, which is not a--
it is not a shoe
in, so to speak,
to use aspheric
optical elements.
So for that reason, we'll
spend quite a bit of time,
and also, I guess,
because of tradition
to analyze what happens
to light as it goes
through spherical surfaces.
So spherical surface, of course.
If you replace the hyperbolas
here with a sphere.
Let's say I take a sphere.
I need to say this very
clearly, because the terms can
become confusing.
If I replace the asphere
with a perfect sphere,
that is, with a ball.
Then, of course, as you can
imagine, what will happen
is the wavefront,
even inside the sphere
will not be planar anymore.
You can convince yourself
if you think about it
that because this sphere
actually bends faster
than the hyperbola, the arrays
that are away from the axes.
They will bend more.
So you get a slightly focusing
in effect inside the sphere.
Because, of course,
not a perfect focus.
It is itself very
high aberrated.
And by the time
they come out, they
become aberrated even more.
So you get a very poor
quality focus in general.
There is a special case
where this might not happen,
but I will skip that for now.
So in general, you get
an aberrated image.
So this is what they meant
before by aberration.
You see that the rays,
they form a blur here.
They fail to meet at
the perfect focus,
as it would have been required
by the perfect optical system.
And this particular
type of aberration
that occurs when you
use a spherical surface
or axis in this system is
called spherical aberration.
Someone asked earlier
about spherical.
This is spherical.
AUDIENCE: I've got a question.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: How do you pick z2?
Like where do you
choose to pick z2?
Is it at the focus
of the closest rays,
or the furthest rays?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: This
came from the hyperbola.
z1, z2, they come
from the hyperbola.
Depending on the curvature
over here, define z1 and z2.
And then I selected
the sphere to match
the curvature of the
hyperbola near to the axis.
So if you look at
the animation again.
Near the axis, you will see that
they actually perfectly match.
But then, of course,
the sphere carves faster
than the hyperbola.
AUDIENCE: I think
the question is
in the spherically aberrated
case where you can not
find all the points meeting,
how can you define the z2?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: OK,
that's a really good question.
So the way you
defined z2 is you look
at the two rays that are really,
really close to the axis.
For those two rays
that are propagating
at the very small angle,
then the same z2 applies.
Then, of course, the
rest of the rays.
They go off very
far from that point.
But anyways, z2 here is exactly
the same as it was before.
Did that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Long
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Now, if you go off axis,
then other types of
aberrations kick in.
So we're not
mentioning them now.
We'll come back to
this topic later,
and we find them in more detail.
But for now, keep this
in mind, that if you
use a sphere on axis.
Let me repeat.
If you use a sphere to
focus a point source on axis
into a point image, also an
axis at the finite distance,
then you get spherical
aberration in general.
Well, that is true, but
if you put it over here.
Just move the axis, yes.
Well, yeah.
OK.
Yeah, thank you.
Let me define what I
mean by the axis here.
So typically, film and
camera is the elements
that we use in order
to capture images flat.
So if I put here
either my camera lens.
I should say the tip of
the camera, the camera
dial, or a film.
That defines an axis that is
perpendicular to the film.
So Colin is correct, that
if I take a point here,
and then move it sort of
radially through the sphere.
It will form a perfect
image over here.
The fact that I try to detect
the image not at this point,
but on the plane, means that I
will be subject to aberrations.
This is the proper
definition of aberration.
And, of course, even
the on axis point
will have spherical aberration,
as I mentioned earlier.
Did I answer that question?
OK, so let's see how we
deal with the refraction
from a sphere.
So [INAUDIBLE],, as
you can imagine,
is a quite complicated
problem because here
is a ray that is arriving from
some point source on axis.
It hits the sphere.
And then my job is to find
which direction this ray
will be refracted
inside the sphere.
So now, again, I can
use one of the tools
that we have in our arsenal.
I can use Fermat's principle,
or I can use Snell's law.
The two are, of
course, identical.
The fact of the matter
is in this case,
it would be quite
complicated to do.
So we'll do simplification.
First of all, let's
define some notation here.
I will denote as x the
distance of the ray
intersects the sphere.
I will define as
alpha left the angle
that the ray makes
with the optical axis
to the left of the interface.
This is the interface.
And then alpha
right is the angle
that the ray makes with
respect to the horizontal,
the optical axis the right
hand side of the interface.
OK, that's my notation.
And now for generality,
I do not assume
that this is air
anymore, I just assume
that I have two dielectrics.
One has index n sub
left, and the other
has index n sub right.
It's a little bit cumbersome
to carry left and right around,
but it is convenient because we
will leave that for a mnemonic
later on.
So how do we solve this problem?
Well, the way I elected to
solve it is a little bit easier,
it turns out.
So for the first
time, today I will not
use Fermat's principle.
I will use Snell's law.
And, of course,
Snell's law follows
from Fermat's principle,
so I haven't really
changed anything.
It's just more convenient
to do the math this way.
So to apply Snell's law,
I have to figure out
which way is the
perpendicular to the interface
at the cross section of the
ray with a spherical surface.
And, of course, if I have
a sphere conveniently,
the normal to the sphere
goes through the center.
So here is the
normal to the sphere.
It goes to the center, and
some additional rotation.
I will denote as R, the
radius of the sphere.
And phi, I will denote the angle
that this particular normal,
this particular radius
makes with, again,
with a horizontal axis.
I think this is all the
notation that I needed.
Actually, I'm not done yet.
So I also to apply Snell's law.
So to apply Snell's law, I
have to look at the angles that
enter Snell's law.
So if you recall, apply
Snell relative to the normal
to the interface.
So here's the normal,
here is the ray.
Therefore, this
angle is theta that
will go on the left-hand
side of Snell's law.
And the corresponding
is theta sub right
that will go to the right-hand
side of Snell's law.
So speaking of which,
here is Snell's law--
n left times the sine of the
angle on the left-hand side
will equal n to the right
times the sine of the angle
on the right-hand side.
And now I have to do a
little a bit of geometry.
So these angles, they
are not known to me yet.
But I can observe
that alpha left
is the same as the angle
from the horizontal
to the ray over here.
And the angle from the
horizontal to the radius
equals 5.
So this means that I have
this property over here--
theta left equals
alpha left plus 5
in the corresponding equation
for the right-hand side.
And I can also substitute
these two relationships
into Snell's law.
I can apply a little
bit of trigonometry
in order to break
the sign of the sum
into this rather
complicated-looking expression
over here.
So I haven't made much progress.
So all I managed to do is
write a complicated set
of trigonometric relationships.
In fact, if I were to
do a numerical solution
to this problem, I would
just stop here and feed it
into a computer and solve.
But I don't want to do that
quite yet, because there's
quite a bit of
intuition to be derived
before we go blindly into a
computer and plug the numerics.
So of course, the thing
that we do in physics
when we try to derive intuition
from a very complicated formula
like this one is we
make approximations.
And the reasonable
approximation to make here
is that the rays that are
arriving to the element
are limited in a relatively
small angular range.
This turns out to be a
very practical assumption,
because it is a very common
situation in optics to have
this small angle approximation.
And it turns out that even when
the small angle approximation
is not exactly
right, you can still
do a first pass of the
design of an optical system
with this approximation.
And then you can
improve it by doing
sort of more complicated
numerical analysis.
So it's a very good place
to start the analysis
of an optical system.
So the key assumption here is
that alpha sub left, this one,
is very small.
If that is true--
and also, I need
one more assumption,
which is that this
distance over here,
the distance that a ray meets
the spherical interface,
is much smaller than the
radius of the sphere.
In other words, the
sphere is not very small,
but it is a relatively
small curvature.
All right?
It has a relatively
large radius of curvature
or, equivalently,
a small curvature.
So the first
answers are correct.
It is also reasonable to
assume that alpha right, so
the right-hand
side of interface,
is also very small angle.
And if I make the
set of assumptions,
the entire set is called
the paraxial approximation.
So "paraxial" really means
that everything is confined
to being near the optical axis.
Very well.
So if we do this approximation
now, a lot of this
gets simplified because
of this Taylor series.
The sine of the angle of a small
angles equals the angle itself.
The cosine of a
small angle equals 1.
And also, the sine of
this angle 5 is equal x/r.
I don't have to touch that one.
This one is actually exact.
But I can also neglect the
cosine of pi, because--
well, because,
again, we are making
the paraxial approximation.
So if I do that, and I do a
little bit of rearrangement
here, I arrive at
this explanation
that says that the
index of the right,
the index to the right
time the angle to the right
equals the index to the
left times the angle
to the left times this
expression over here.
You might wonder a
number of things.
For example, why did I
leave the index here?
I'm looking for alpha right.
So why don't I just divide
along and get done with it?
There is a reason.
And it will become
apparent in the moment.
But for now, I'm
almost done, right?
I have managed to
do what I wanted.
I have a pretty
closed-form expression
for the angle of refraction
inside the sphere.
Now I'm going to do
something really strange.
I will derive a
similar expression
for light propagating
in uniform space.
Now, this sounds
totally useless, right?
But let me do it anyway.
And bear with me for a while.
I have a ray which is
propagating in free space.
For reasons of notation, I will
define two refractive indices
that are equal.
One is n left, one is n right.
But they're both equal to the
same index of refraction n.
And what I'm interested to do
is I'm interested in relating
the angle of the ray on the
left-hand side with respect
to this reference plane
over here and the elevation
of the ray with respect to
the same plane with the same
quantities at the
second reference plane--
the elevation and the angle
of the right-hand side.
[? There ?] are other
trivial problem,
because, for example, Fermat
says that in free space,
the ray must propagate
at a straight line.
So therefore, I can immediately
derive that alpha left
equals alpha right.
Not very surprising, right?
I'm stating the
obvious here, and I'm
making a big deal out of it.
But nevertheless, let
me write it like this.
Since the indices are
the same, I can also
multiply by those indices.
And what about the elevations?
Well, the elevations
satisfy a simple equation
relating the tangent of the
angle of propagation multiplied
by the propagation distance d.
So the elevation to the
right equals the elevation
to the left times this--
time this quantity.
And then in the spirit of the
paraxial approximation again,
I'm going to drop the
tangent, because the tangent
of a small angle equals
the angle itself.
And I arrive at a
set of equations,
x right equals x left
plus d times alpha left.
And this equation
that I got before.
So now let me put
the two together.
Let me put the free space
propagation that I just
derived, and relationship
between the ray elevation
and the ray angle to the
left and to the right
of a uniform space
of distance d,
and the equation that
I just derived earlier
for the refraction of a ray
from a spherical surface,
spherical refractive
surface, of radius r.
OK.
So these are the two sets
of equations that we got.
This is the set of equations
that I got immediately before.
And this is the set of equations
that I saw that I got earlier
when I solved the
refraction problem
at the spherical interface.
And again, I want to
emphasize that both of these
are correct in the
paraxial approximation.
These are not exact expressions.
The equal sign is a
bit of an ambiguous
here, because I've
sort of assumed
that the paraxial
approximation is correct.
So we're going on with
this assumption now.
That's why I'm
putting equal signs.
OK.
And I added one
more equation that I
didn't write before that
says that x to the left
equals x to the right.
In this case-- and this
is a trivial thing--
it says that the
ray is continuous.
It arrives at the interface
at the center point
and leaves from the same point.
And that's kind of obvious.
The ray should not jump.
So what is remarkable
about these equations
is that they're
both fully there,
and the relations--
and the quantities
that they're linear
with respect to
are these two
elements, the elevation
and the angle of the ray.
So you can think of them as
kind of transport equations.
They allow you to
transport a ray from two
very basic optical elements.
One is free space propagation.
It allows you to transport
a ray through uniform space.
And the other is a
refractive interface.
Again, it allows you
to transport the ray
from the left to the right
of a refractive interface.
And because they're linear,
we can also write them
in matrix form as follows.
This is not new.
I just took these
equations and rewrote them.
And I rewrote them in
a slightly funny way.
I kept the index of
refraction times the angle.
Can anybody-- now that
we see it in this form--
I will go to the
matrix in a moment.
But now that you
see it in this form,
can anybody guess why did I
go through all this trouble
to keep the index of
refraction in this expression?
Why don't I just write
the angle by itself?
Is there a case, a
situation that we've
seen, where this quantity may
be conserved, for example?
AUDIENCE: You have the
dispersion thing again.
Or where it depends-- where you
have different n's, I suppose,
and therefore different angles
depending on your wavelengths.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah.
Even simpler, actually.
If you are think
of Snell's law--
yeah, you're on the
right track there.
If you think of Snell's
law, Snell's law
says that n left sine
alpha left equals
n right sine alpha right.
And of course, in the
paraxial approximation
I drop the sinusoids.
So therefore, I arrive
to the conclusion
that this quantity at the
first element of this vector
is actually conserved.
And [INAUDIBLE] of
course, you can go over it
yourselves and
convince yourselves
that the equation is correct.
This is basically just
taking the same equation.
And these matrices, we'll
use them in the next lecture
in order to do ray tracing.
So basically, an optical
element can always
be decomposed in a sequence
of refractive interfaces
and free space or uniform
space propagation.
So the reason the
matrices are convenient--
sort of jumping
ahead a little bit--
is because if you have a
cascade of optical elements,
then you can ray trace simply
by multiplying these matrices.
I will do that in detail in
the next lecture next Monday.
But this is why we went
through all this trouble
to derive the
paraxial approximation
and then write it out
in this matrix form,
so that we can use matrix
properties to do ray tracing.
Then there's one more
thing before we quit.
Do you see Snell's law in
any of these laws over here?
You can see Snell's law on the
handwritten slide over here.
But how about-- what about here?
Can you see Snell's
law somewhere?
Another way to ask my question--
these are questions
that I wrote here.
Can they capture
Snell's law in some way?
Do they include it?
How?
AUDIENCE: The elevation
doesn't change if we apply it
at a point the interfaces.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: OK.
That is correct.
Yeah, that's correct.
OK.
Maybe I should restate--
I asked the question
in a confusing way.
The Snell's law at
the flat interface--
the same that I
rewrote over here--
can I get it somehow
from this equation?
What is the radius of
curvature of this surface?
Infinity, right?
So if I plug in infinity, if
I plugged r equals infinity,
in this case of
course, physically what
happens is the
interface becomes flat.
Is the equation over
here, this term goes away.
And I get what?
I get-- n left alpha
left, n right alpha right,
x left, x right.
So you write x left
equals x right,
but also n left alpha left
equals n right alpha right,
which is actually Snell's law.
So this-- again, I'm restating
something that I said before--
this is the reason why
we put this product
in the top element of the vector
when we write this expression.
OK.
So we've run out of time.
So any questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Oh, you're right.
I'm sorry.
This would be 1, 0.
Yeah.
I'll fix the notes.
There's a typo.
The first matrix should be 1,
0, and then the rest is correct.
Yeah, thank you.
Did everybody hear that?
There's a typo in the notes.
The elements of the first row of
this matrix need to be swapped.
OK.
So I'll see you all next Monday.